kari was ist dein lieblingsobst mein
lieblings offs ist schokoladeneis
gratulationen okay ich zeig dir was mein
lieblingsort ist ein moment wo cadooz
bananen
das ist mein lieblings ochs und 1 mein
lieblings obst sind äpfel
ich esse fast jeden tag mindestens zwei
äpfel apfelsaft bist du und das ist
jetzt unsere frage oder was unsere frage
wie heute ist welches obst die menschen
gerne mögen und dann machen wir unseren
kleinen bananen und apfel countern ecke
ja wenn du die energie dafür hast dann
wird es auch da sinnlos
los geht's
[Musik]
magst du obst ja ich mag obst und
welches obst magst du am liebsten
wassermelone und erdbeeren und himbeeren
obst ja natürlich und welches obst mögen
sie am liebsten
ich bin der einzige ex liebe mag schon
als einheimischer auch äpfel birnen
pfirsiche mango kirchen etwa mango apfel
und was essen sie am häufigsten am obst
orangen und äpfel und wie viele obst ist
so am tag und welches jeden tag auf
jeden fall viel also auf jeden fall
apfel und banane
ich mache mir jeden morgen müsli mit
obst und woher wusstest du dass eine
melone obst isst und was ist kürbis auch
obst oder gemüse gemüse obst nicht
welches obst mögen sie am liebsten jetzt
überlegen
ich glaube ich habe gerade in kamerun
frisch vom acker ananas gegessen und das
war so gut können sie sich nicht
vorstellen aber sie essen an das
bestimmt nicht jeden tag oder und was
ist dieses alltägliche obst war sie
jeden tag ist ein apfel oder gewonnen
und essen sie äpfel jeden tag und
schälen sie die äpfel oder essen sie sie
zu sagen ich es inzwischen so beim bio
äpfel sind aber nur stellen sie die
äpfel
nein
was machen sie mit den nerven und
schälen sie die äpfel oder nicht nein
die orangen klar ja und stellen sie den
apfel oder essen sie den was soll da
blitzen
ich denke dass dies nicht die vitamine
dann treffe das bezweifle ich eben weil
ich glaube und wie bereitet deine mama
diätpillen vor
warum denn nicht
erdbeeren sind glitter weil die nicht
bio sind und eine aubergine ist nein und
gibt es auch sorten die ehe überhaupt
nicht mögt pokal ocado ist nicht mein
geschmack an
das nicht
diese frage wo kader ist obst und tomate
auch und eine tomate gemüse
aber das interessiert mich nicht weil es
weil das nicht süß welches welches obst
magst du am meisten
[Musik]
ich habe keine richtige keinen richtigen
favoriten ehrlich gesagt und welches ob
siehst du ganz offen
bananen wahrscheinlich banana banane und
ist sie einfach so spontan oder bereit
ist die bahnen bannern irgendwie mit
müsli oder in einen milchshake ja ich
mache immer meine sheikh rein bevor ist
manchmal zum sport gehen oder so also
ist es etwas einfach sorge scheele
erstmal und die banane und dann es ist
und welches magst du neben der banane
auch noch erdbeeren und sind tomaten
obst oder gemüse für mich gemüse und
wissenschaftlich auch gemüse obst sehen
sie man gerade in berlin angekommen ich
lebe in münchen
lerne ich doch gleich noch was welches
benutzt um einen obstsalat zu machen das
was gerade da ist alles möglich sei und
was ist krank erdbeeren äpfel wasser -
orange oder banane nicht banane ist
gemüse sein sondern ist auch aufs und
kürbis selten ist so groß für eine
person macht nicht so gut
obst oder gemüse wenn ich mich jetzt
verfahren muss es ja wieder auf seine ja
richtig passt und welche magst du
überhaupt nicht wobei erschienen
ich habe mich so eine komische kleine
orangene frucht gekauft aber ich weiß
nicht wie die heißt die war ziemlich
ekelhaft
ich kenne kein obst dass ich nicht mag
wenn ich jetzt mach ich überhaupt nicht
ist sicher ist gerade gar keins ehrlich
gesagt ich weiß es nicht und welches
obst magst du noch
ich liebe himbeere auch diesen lecker
lecker und nein meine oma sie hat
erdbeeren und himbeeren bei ihr besucht
deine oma und dann kannst du erdbeeren
und himbeeren essen bereiten sie schon
ab und zu ein obstsalat nein ja nicht
und machen sie manchmal eine obst suppe
auch nicht dass doch noch ein kürbis ja
doch mit kürbis ich komme aus polen wir
haben die tradition im sommer für kinder
immer ob suppen zu machen und ist eine
tomate obst oder gemüse eigentlich für
mich gemüse aber eigentlich ist es obst
also ich weiß dass das thema chips ist
ich wusste nicht dass ich hoffe wir
haben dir nichts zerstört das ist in
ordnung
mache ich mir jetzt morgen man muss ein
bisschen tomate und was ist eine
aubergine
das ist das leckerste gemüse der welt
auch gewisse und jetzt wollen wir von
euch wissen was ist euer lieblingsobst
schreibt uns auf deutsch ein kommentar
unten in den kommentaren
und wenn er weiter deutsch lernen wollt
werdet mitglied bei easyjet und lernt
mit interaktiven übungen weiter
danke sie und ciao
[Musik]